what do you wish more people knew about
how stress impacts the human
body
um that
while it's worth paying attention to the
fact that it does crummy things to your
heart and blood pressure and bladder and
everything else uh for me most
meaningful thing is it does crummy
things to your brain the worst is that
it makes you less empathic it makes you
less tolerant it makes you less willing
to take somebody else's perspective it
Narrows your tunnel of concerns and I
think what we see is in a world full of
stress uh people are crummier to each
other on the
average why does stress cause that
reduction in
empathy all sorts of interesting stuff
various places in the brain but in one
region uh we think we colleagues and I
and lots of other people in the field um
think we've gotten a sense of the brain
region that's relevant something called
the anterior singulate cortex and if you
want to summarize it uh this is the part
of the brain where you feel someone
else's
pain sit someone down stick them in a
brain scanner poke their finger with a
pin and like all sorts of ouch parts of
the brain activate and as part of that
this part of the brain anterior single
it also activates and it's got a lot to
do with interpreting what the pain means
that sort of thing like you poke
somebody with a pin uh after you've told
them they've just had this very powerful
anesthetic cream smeared over their
finger when in actuality it's like cream
cheese or something and they don't feel
the pain the parts of their brain that
are saying ouch that was in my finger
are still going on but anterior singula
has gone silent because you have fallen
for a placebo effect it's it's about the
interpretation of the pain rather than
the nuts and bolts features of it so now
stick the person in the brain scander
and don't poke their finger with a pin
make them watch their loved one have
their finger poked and the panometer
Brain regions have nothing to say
because like nobody's doing anything to
your finger tip but the anterior
singulate activates and neurons there on
this very like simplistic level can't
tell the difference between your pain
and someone else's pain um big amazing
sort of footnote in there uh typically
people suffering from major depression
this part of the brain is overactive
it's just pain 247 wherever you look and
that kind of thing okay so it turns out
that when people are stressed they
become less generous they're more likely
to cheat in a economic game their moral
compass goes out the window their their
range of concern Narrows down to people
who look just like me and pray like me
and eat like me and all that sort of
stuff that we're way familiar with um
and it turns out what stress hormones
are also doing is disrupting the
functioning of this part of the brain
and there's like a drug you can give to
rats or give to college freshman
volunteers which will block the effects
of a stress hormone and when you throw
that in there uh they maintain their
empathy despite being stressed they
maintain all sorts of physiological
markers of it we're feeling less
capacity to look at somebody else's pain
and somebody else's perspective on the
world when we're stressed because what
matters has turned into a very
self-interested Focus for most people so
like amid stress doing terrible things
to your memory and your executive
function and judgment and all sorts of
stuff this increasingly strikes me as
this this is The Outpost that's really
interesting one of the things that
continues to come up in your work on
stress is this uh it's almost like an
agentic view of what's happening to you
it's it's how much agency do you have is
this kind of being imposed on me or have
I selected that this is going to happen
what is the role
of agency and of valtion when it comes
to stress and how we interpret
it well it falls under the rubric of how
I think everything in the universe works
which is like there's no agency at all
there's no free will um in recent years
I've stopped spending most most of my
time fussing around with one neuron at a
time and soaking in stress hormones and
getting much more interested in larger
issues
of biology of who we are and how we got
here and our best moments and our worst
moments and everything Ambiguously in
between and when you spend enough time
like obsessing over biology and how it
interacts with environment and all the
things that came for us that we had no
control over both biologically
environmentally you reach this
conclusion somewhere in there that
there's no damn Free Will whatsoever it
is entirely a myth so this is this is my
current song and dance trying to
convince the word world that
uh this is uh how things work well if we
want to increase the stress in everybody
at least for a short term perhaps that
that's a nice little teaser for what
we're going to get on to talk to me
because obviously short-term stress is
useful long-term stress not useful is
there a line is am I not supposed to be
stressed after 8 hours and 35 minutes
when when does short-term stress start
to become bad well it depends on who you
are and your place in society and what
culture and as long as we're at it what
species you are and sort of the the the
central Concept in stress is like you
get stuck in a traffic jam you're
stressed you do this with this hormone
you turn off this other one your your
blood pressure does whatever and the
amazing thing is if you went back a
hundred million years and some like
twerpy little dinosaur was being chased
by someone terrifying that dinosaur
would have been secreting the precise
same molecules that you do when you're
stuck in traffic or thinking about
global warming or who it's an incredibly
ancient piece of art like wiring it's
the same thing in Us and other primates
and mammals and fish and birds and
reptiles and ampi it's incredibly
conserved stuff and what it's been doing
for like 150 million years or so is
saving your life when you were facing a
short-term physical crisis somebody is
very intent on eating you you are very
intent on eating somebody else because
you're starving and everything that it
does is get your body for dealing with
the next three minutes of Crisis you're
mobilizing energy from storage sites to
deliver to the muscles that are saving
your neck you're increasing heart rate
blood pressure you're turning off
everything unessential in your body in
the hopes that there is a later you'll
take care of it later growth tissue
repair immune surveillance reproduction
all of that all built around like triage
everything that's not essential to next
three minutes and then you get us smart
primates us humans who could anticipate
our deaths or some like low ranking
baboon who spends his entire life not
being chased by lias but being hassled
by higher ranking guys and what you've
invented is this like totally corrosive
disastrous chronic psychosocial stress
and you see this very simple outcome you
go sprinting for your life and your
blood pressure is way way elevated this
is a good thing it's saving your life
you day after day deal with an abusive
boss or you have an anxiety disorder or
whatever and you're doing the same thing
with your cardiovascular system and
you're going to blow it apart because
the system didn't evolve for being
turned on chronically and for most
beasts it's either over with after three
minutes or you're over with and we're
capable of doing this like for months
years on end and that's not what the
system evolved for and that's why us and
a few other primates are smart enough to
get sick from psychological stress yeah
the idea the concept of being smart
enough to get sick from psychological
stress is is an odd sort of twisting of
the words but I suppose it's very true
right because if we didn't have this
unbelievable abstraction ability to be
able to contemplate am I really speaking
my truth forward is this my highest
actualization maybe that cookie that I
ate yesterday really does say everything
about me that I've always thought that
it was ruminating about that weird thing
you said to a teacher 15 years ago
whatever it might be that you're
vacillating about we are able to
abstract our stresses and ruminate about
them and continue to cause them to
persist in our mind even when they're
not there so even if we're not being
chased by said dinosaur or or tiger or
baboon we can imagine all of the
previous baboons and tigers and
dinosaurs that we thought about getting
chased from and still get the same
physiological effect yes as well as
remember our most incompetent
embarrassing social moments of Our Lives
as well as imagine that you're destined
to do something like that over and over
again in the future as well as worry
about worry about a movie character you
watch somebody on a screen or you read a
a novel and you activate a stress
response because oh no watch out the bad
guys are coming up behind you or you're
heartbroken you know at the end of a
novel by some beloved character getting
done in or worse and most meaningfully
you sit there and you read about what's
happening in Ukraine or banglades and
you do the exact same thing we're taking
this 150 million year old circuitry and
we can abstracted over space and time
like nothing that's ever walked this
planet before right with this
perspective the kind of trite cliche of
people saying humans are not meant to
consume the entire world's catastrophes
24 hours a day in real time this is
presumably having a real genuine impact
on our stress response and therefore
Health outcomes physiology hormones all
of that stuff yeah exactly and you know
to show how similar things are and then
how different you take a female baboon
this was some great research done some
Years Ago by some colleagues and she has
an infant and the infant does there's a
high infant mortality rate and they
could show up to a month later not only
is this female more socially withdrawn
doing less grooming all she has elevated
stress hormone level she is mourning for
a month afterward and that sure looks
familiar and often she will carry the
body around for days afterward wow that
looks just like us and then we do the
same thing when we see that Bambi's
mother was killed in the in the cartoon
and we're haunted by that for year whoa
we can take this very primate thing my
child has died and we're feeling upset
about an animated cartoon character
we're you know we could just extended in
ways that's
unrecognizable to other
species I learned from you that a third
trimester fetus's brain development is
impacted by the mother's socioeconomic
status how screwed is that how insane
absolutely insane in you're born and you
are already screwed by having picked the
wrong womb um take that from the top for
me take that from the absolute top okay
well you know people used to realize
poverty social instability being a
peripheralized outgroup the wrong
ethnicity the wrong race the wrong all
of those things what do you know your
body like pays a big price in the United
States for example if you are
africanamerican on the average your
chromosomes are aging at an accelerated
rate compared to everybody else because
stress hormones mess up the enzymes that
keep your chromosomes young and like
whoa like the chromosomes and your cells
are falling apart faster so whoo no
surprise no surprise and when you look
at like Health socioeconomic status is a
gigantic predictor am I assuming
correctly you're in the UK Austin Texas
but I was in the UK for a very long time
I'm I'm an adop e over here okay well no
wonder you've got that Texan accent um
you know the classic whiteall studies of
civil servants and written and stuff
your socioeconomic rank has an enormous
impact on your body and it's got nothing
to do with getting healthc care access
it's got very little to do with the fact
that like you can't afford your health
club memberships it's stress it's the
psychosocial effects of like chronically
having no control no predictability all
of that and then they figured out that
like the socioeconomic status of your
family when you were a kid is predictive
of all sorts of unhealthy stuff when
you're 60 years old
and then among other things uh people
got brain Imaging techniques cool enough
that they could now brain image of fetus
and see how it's doing and back came the
finding that already as a fetus your
mother's socioeconomic status uh has an
impact on your brain growth how does
that happen very simple if you're poor
and if you're chronically socially
psychosocially stressed for any of Gaz
and other reasons you've got elevated
levels of these stress hormones in your
bloodstream and they get through the
placenta and they get to your fetus and
have all sorts of effects while the
fetus's body is learning what kind of
world it is out there whoa It's a scary
one it's an unpredictable one these
stress hormones having all sorts of
effects on how you're
constructing every Outpost including
your brain and it turns out some of the
fanciest parts of your brain your
frontal cortex Etc are very sensitive to
these stress hormones and their
maturation is impaired by them yeah what
are the outcomes what are what are the
sort of outcomes that you see from a
mother that is low socioeconomic status
perhaps highly chronically stressed what
is the sort of brain or the sort of
person that will be born out of that
more than likely well this one isn't
well understood yet because these are
the first studies coming out this is
officially cutting a Cutting Edge
neuroimaging techniques but we already
know a ton just a few years later get a
kid by the time they're five years old
going into kid kindergarten and on the
average their family socioeconomic
status is already a predictor of this
kid's resting stress hormone levels how
screwed is that and on the average it's
already predictive of the maturation of
the front cortex in this kid how thick
this cortical region is what its
metabolic rate is like and one wonders
so what does this part of the brain do
that I keep mentioning um it's the brain
region that lets you be self-disciplined
and longterm planning and impulse
control and emotional regulation I don't
know a lot of a lot of people will be
familiar with like the famed marshmallow
test with like five-year-old kids and oh
my God that's it's amazing you get a
5-year-old who can't hold out for the
second marshmallow and they're they're
on it within seconds and all of that and
this is predictive decades decades later
of this kid's cumulative earnings over
their lifetime their adult socioeconomic
status there patterns of metabolic
diseases cardiovascular wo already at
age five the the the die is not cast
unchangeably but it's already leaning in
a fairly significant direction by age
five that's already a predictor of what
things are going to look like as an
adult in lots of these important Realms
and by age five if you once again pick
the wrong family to be born into and
you're already marinating in chronic
psychosocial stress because you know
your family's poverty by age five you
already have that profile that's
predictive of you know that outcome that
is on the less uh desirable side long
afterward absolutely insane it's I had a
Robert pman on the show um I've spent a
good bit of time learning about
behavioral genetics over the last couple
of years and what I'm really fascinated
about is this odd intersection between
nature and nurture the fact that you are
your parents are predisposed to behave
in a way which creates the nurture their
predisposition has to be inherited by
you at least in part because that is the
nature element of what's going on so
when you have this very odd blending
let's say that you have a mother who is
uh predisposed to be a little bit more
anxious okay so perhaps you have got a
predisposition to be a little bit more
anxious but then what's the environment
in that you grow up in right you already
have this sort of precursor Downstream
from that mothers that say overbearingly
you can't go out without your coat on
and make sure that you ring me before
this what's the subtext that you're
being taught there that the world is a
scary place that you need to be very
concerned that you must always be
vigilant and you've already got this
predisposition it's this fascinating
intersection and the interplay between
the two that I think is is really
interesting in behavioral genetics an
incredibly important one and behavioral
genetics has kind of uh I don't mean
this too pejoratively but grown up um to
the extent of realizing when it comes to
behavior genes are very very very rarely
determinant they're about
vulnerabilities they're about potential
they're about you know skating on the
edge of something and it depends on what
environment you wind up in whether
you're pushed over the edge it depends
if you have the right nurturant things
that you've got the genetic potential
all set to take advantage of it after a
while is irrelevant to ask what does
this Gene do but only to ask what a gene
does in this particular type of
environment great example of this in
terms of stress and genetic
vulnerability uh classic study it's been
mired in some controversy for years but
I think it's the most important study
done in biological psychiatry in a
quarter Century there's this Gene it's
got something to do with serotonin this
neurotransmitter in the brain everybody
knows serotonin has something to do with
depression ssris like Prozac work on it
um so it's this that comes in a few
different flavors and all sorts of
animal studies suggested you wind up
with this flavor and you're Miss more at
risk for depression um and that made
perfect sense and whoa that say that you
know suggests all sorts of genetic uh
impact on depression and such let's go
look at some humans and this amazing
study following like thousands of people
from childhood up into like early
adulthood where you've got their genomes
and you're saying well does having like
the scary vulnerable version of this
Gene increase your risk for having a
history of depression by the time you're
25 years old and the answer was
absolutely clear yes yes it increases
the risk if and only if you had a lot of
stressors during
childhood in the absence of a stressful
childhood having that risk variant had
virtually no impact whatsoever it's not
the genetics of becoming depressed it's
the genetics of being more vulnerable to
depression when it's coupled with huge
amounts of stress early in life and this
turns out to be the theme with like
everything implicated with genes and
behavior it depends on the environment
that you're in and what do you know it
turns out all sort of these genetic risk
profiles uh when it's coupled with a
stressful environment an abusive one a
neglectful one what that's the
circumstances in which they suddenly are
adverse yeah it's interesting to think
about um let's say you had some child
that was 99th percentile
conscientiousness you know full standard
deviation higher in IQ all of like some
stuff big predisposition but they were
born into an environment or a culture
that wasn't really pushing them to use
that discipline and that motivation and
and that sort of Drive perhaps they're
born into somewhere that doesn't even
have a formal education system you think
okay well what what ability do they have
to be able to capitalize on this and
again another fascinating thing is we've
moved recently only in the last sort of
100 150 years from a Brawn based to a
brain-based economy which has meant that
people who had a competitive Advantage
only two centuries ago if that same
disposition was born now they totally
different what are you going to do with
your ability to dig 8 hours a day
without getting back pain I get back
pain right I'm not going to be I'm not
going to be good I'm not going to be
good on the on the digs um what do
people get wrong so what you've said
there sounds tenuously close to what
people who don't understand epigenetics
on the internet say is
epigenetics that sounds to me like the
sort of epigenetics of the gaps that
they would say you see the genes aren't
turned on and then the environment turns
them on is that epigenetics and if not
what is epigenetics related to it well
actually that's like epigenetics I I
can't give a much more accurate
description of it than that uh you got
your
genes DNA sequence long strings of them
specifying proteins that you make um and
it turns out like 95% of your DNA
doesn't specify
genes it's the instruction manual it's
the on and off switches for when you
activate or deactivate the genes in
particular circumstances in this part of
your body but not in that part and so on
um and it turns out very little of
environment changes your actual DNA
sequences and the stuff that does is
like bad stuff like radiation things
like not not not stuff thinking about
here yes for example all those all those
three-headed dogs running around there
with the with the Russian troops um but
what environment what experience
does is messes with the onoff switches
and epigenetics is the fancy term for
the fact that experience doesn't change
your genes but it changes the regulation
of them often really for a long time
often lifelong often through some
incredibly cool mechanisms
multi-generationally this is
how like you're a fetus and you're being
soaked in a lot of stress hormones
and what are they doing they're causing
epigenetic effects on onoff switches in
the brain that unless you intervene
pretty like majorly later on are going
to be lifelong this is exactly Mech
epigenetics is just the fancy term for
wait a second stuff that happens to you
is going to make a difference 50 years
later it's going to make a difference in
your disease risks your diet early in
life has epigenetic effects on how good
your pain pancreas is reacting to
glucose in your bloodstream when you're
80 so epigenetics is just the trendy
term for saying the interesting stuff
about genes is much less the genes
themselves than their regulation and
what environment does is change the
regulation to your
genes that's fascinating maybe the
people on Twitter were right all along
so it sounds to me like you're
saying bad stuff not only leaves scar
tissue for you and not just for you now
but you in the future and then also
potentially your kids as well
presumably yeah through mechanisms well
you've already mentioned one mechanism
which is like the regulation that
happened to your genes and the Brain you
got right now as an adult is going to
influence how you how you raise your
child and you know what what parents
spend an awful lot of time doing is
trying to figure out ways to make their
kid just like that when they grow up to
have the same cultural values to have
the same Neurosis because those don't
seem like Neurosis they seem like the
only sensible way to go about handling
the world all of that so there's
multi-generational transmission through
parenting style through culture all of
that but multigenerational epigenetic
stuff also arises from unbelievably
cruel mechanisms okay for example so you
are that fetus and Mom is stressed as
hell because she has an anxiety disorder
for example and thus you're being soaked
in a lot of the physiological
consequences of her anxiety disorder and
that influences your brain and among
other things it causes epigenetic
changes in one part of your brain called
the amydala the amydala is about fear
anxiety all of that and what does a lot
of stress early in life including during
fetal life thanks to those hormones do
it makes your migdala grow bigger than
normal you wind up having as an adult on
the average an amydala that's enlarged
that's hyperactive that's hysterical
that sees Menace that other people don't
things of that sort okay so you got this
and like with the right therapy at the
right points in life you can actually
reverse epigenetic stuff wow get the
right talk therapy and like your genes
are regulated differently in your brain
yeah it's got to that that's like when
therapy works but if you haven't had
that good fortune now you're an adult
with your enlarged amydala and you get
pregnant and because of that big amydala
you secrete elevated levels of stress
hormones because that's and thus your
fetus's amydala will be bigger than
expected and thus when they are an adult
and you have these multi-generational
Ripples and this is not passing on genes
this is passing on the adverse
regulatory consequences for your genes
and this stuff is multigenerational it's
not inevitable you are not damning a 100
generations of descendants and like you
could intervene and very little in US is
set in stone but all things being equal
this is even a way to pass the stuff
unto the generations Beyond
you wow you mentioned interventions
there we are bathed in
stresses I don't know how full Andrew
huberman mode you have gone in your work
to look at ameliorating or mitigating
this has there been anything that or or
what is the 30,000 foot view of how to
think about strategies that are good at
reducing stress what what what is the
like way to conceptualize it
well what I can say confidently is
you're asking the entirely wrong
question to this person because I'm
terrible at handling stress like why
else do you spend decades like living in
a laboratory thinking about this so
research is me search Robert research is
me search yes sublimate it all into
those test tubes and those statistical
tests um so I happen to be lousy it so
anything I have to say here take with a
grain of salt but what the real experts
show is you know what what is stress
about not when you're being chased by a
dinosaur but when you're being
psychologically stressed what is it that
makes psychological stress stressful
it's for the same external reality for
the same external
unpleasantry if you feel like you have
no control if you feel like you're
getting no predictive information about
when is it going to come and how long is
it going to last and bad is it going to
be when you have no outlets for the
frustration caused by the stresser when
you interpret things as meaning things
are getting worse rather than better and
when you got no social support
incredibly like elegant powerful studies
showing stuff like with a lab rat or
with a college student you give them
shocks every now and then they get a
stress response and you give them a
little warning like 10 seconds before
each shock they don't get as much of a
stress respon response you've given them
predictive
information let them press a lever
repeatedly where they think that by
pressing the lever decreases the
likelihood of a shock the lever's doing
nothing it's a placebo it's disconnected
yet merely by feeling like you have some
sense of control just imagine how worse
it would have been if I were not the
captain of my ship you buffer against so
hugely important psychological variables
in there but what you see is like it's
narrow ranges where this is predictive
information give that little warning
light one second before the shock
doesn't do you any good it's not enough
time to get the right psychological
perspective give the warning light a
minute before each shock and you make
things worse because rather than sitting
there saying oh what a magnificent life
I have where I know when my stressors
are coming and now I can prepare for my
coping stra you're sitting there for a
whole minute so whoa so it's not just
have more pred addictive information
have more of a sense of control you
don't want to give somebody a sense of
control when the outcome was a disaster
because all you're doing is biasing them
towards thinking how much better things
could have been and too bad I was at
control at that time and some of the
most Humane stuff we do is try to
minimize somebody's sense of control in
the face of it nobody could have stopped
the car the way that child darted out it
wouldn't have made a difference if you
had gotten them to the doctor earlier
there's nothing that you couldn't have
done anything the sense of control only
works for mild to moderate stressors for
big disastrous ones help that person
deceive themselves like crazy because
that's where the so it's not just you
know get as much control and as much
predictability and as much social
support as possible because like often
we mistake like superficial
acquaintanceships for actual social
support and like it sucks when the
carpet gets pulled out from under your
feet that it turns out that clubbing is
not the way in which you meet people who
will keep you through the moments of
crisis in your life um you know narrow
range where all this stuff works um
sound bites and once again the terrain
where do as I say not as I live um but
you know all the stress management stuff
collectively can work quite well um it's
not stuff you save for the weekend it's
not stuff you save until like your on
hold on the phone kind of thing um it's
something you got to set time out for
every day and usually a block of time
and what's interesting is whether that's
like exercise or meditation or playing
your OBO or whatever it is that's doing
it for you um actually doing that
activity is stress reducing but the mere
fact that IM mid your life of saying I
can't say no to this I got to get this
done I got to get that done all these
pressures if you were willing to say no
to that stuff enough if you were willing
to consider your well-being to be
important enough that you stop
everything for 20 minutes a day of like
you know messing with Rubik's Cubes it
hardly matters what you're doing you're
90% of the way they're already because
you have said this is serious enough and
my well-being is serious enough that I'm
going to say no to all these things I
can't say no to so like that works great
um next thing is make sure it's a Stress
Management technique that like you
actually enjoy doing like because if it
isn't you shouldn't be getting stressed
by doing your Stress Management
technique exactly like you know
meditation there's a gazillion study
showing it has all sorts of benef
beneficial effects because of my makeup
if I spent 20 minutes a day meditating I
would have a stroke by this weekend it's
so like antithetical to what my makeup
is but like that's great that all your
friends say it's
wonderful you know see if it works for
you read the fine print um and if it
doesn't like that's not stress reduction
that's exactly the opposite I would say
the last caveat that comes with that is
if you've run into somebody who says it
has been scientifically proven that
their special brand of stress management
works better than the other ones you got
to do it almost every day and it's got
to be something that actually works for
you rather than working for whichever
celebrity in their like exercise routine
is talking about on online and like
don't trust someone who says theirs is
special because they all are roughly
doing the same
thing talking about on the other side of
this moving out of stress and into good
stuff have you ever thought about how
people can help themselves habituate to
the good things and the good changes
that happen in life more
slowly yeah um something I've been
ruminating on a lot as of late because
you know it's another one of those we're
we're a weird species and it allows us
to do some cool stuff but whoa does it
have some like bills that come afterward
in terms of no free lunch okay so you're
a
baboon like what's the source of fun in
your life you're hungry and you get to
eat something great or like you're in a
bad mood and you get to beat up on
somebody smaller so you feel terrific or
somebody mates with you or any of these
things and like it's a fairly limited
repertoire of what counts is
rewarding and then you get to us and
like all of those things are nice but in
addition like we solve a math problem
that we've been working on for 20 years
and like the world is wondrous place or
like a piece of music or like quadruple
orgasms or like you smell a flower that
smells great or like we've got this
range of potential Pleasures that's
amazing compared to every other Beast
out there and once again this theme of
we're just like every other primate out
there until you look close and we're
totally different we've got the same
brain circuitry that handles reward and
anticipation and motiv ation as every
other like primate out there and a lot
of it revolves around this
neurotransmitter dopamine and dopamine's
totally cool and it's reward but it's
actually more about anticipation than
reward and if you're a baboon dopamine
is all about wow this like gazelle I
just killed is going to be fantastic
this is going to taste great and then we
do stuff like we release the same
neurotransmitter thinking about wow this
is going to be such a great planet for
my grandchild children or wow this is
you know we've got this range of
potential pleasures and potential
motivations like nobody else out there
and the range varies like this is a
system that has to accommodate smelling
a nice flower and winning the lottery
and it's using the same circuits and
it's using the same neurotransmitters to
do this what that means is this is a
system that has to reset really quickly
because it's got to know okay okay we
just stopped doing winning the lottery
now we're doing the smell of flowers so
like going from zero to 10 okay we've
readjusted this is what 0o to 10 now
means this is like the first nice smell
of the Season rather than oh you've just
cured
world hunger or whatever uh it's got to
reset quickly and there's some cool h H
coming up by now as to what's unique
about the human like reward anticipation
system where it's got fancier regulation
so you could send more negative feedback
signals saying okay we're switching from
flowers to orgasms now or whatever where
it's got very fancy s so that's totally
great that allows us to do stuff and
there's like the bill that comes which
accounts for an incredibly percent
incredible percentage of like
human disease and despair and
dissatisfaction which is if this system
resets so quickly by definition whatever
was like a fantastic surprise and
wonderful yesterday is going to be what
you feel entitled to
today and is going to feel insufficient
tomorrow and we get hungry again and we
just get hungry and hungry and hungry
and whatever was great is never going to
be enough very quickly and like okay
that's why we go to the moon and that's
why we like do incredible motivated
things and we innovate and we always
want the next new thing and Novelty and
all that but it's also why with like
Damn Few tragically few exceptions we
habituate to great stuff and it never
tastes as good again and never feels as
good again or feels as satisfying or and
like this is this crappy miserable thing
we're stuck in as a species you know if
we're going to like send in tens of
thousands of patents for new things
every year um the downside is what was
wonderful stop seeming wonderful pretty
quickly we habituate like mad and like
that that's our that's our like basic
predicament it stops feeling is good and
we get hungry
again okay so when it comes to extending
how long that happens is there anything
that we can do can we slow this
inevitable onslaught of honic
adaptation um oh sure you you have to be
a hell of a lot more mature than I am
for example and you know far more you
know all the stuff like go through these
like cognitive exercises of think about
somebody else who's less lucky than you
or try to really file away that feeling
of like glorious surprise and like this
is great and this is like a wonderful
loving caring world and I'm okay and
it's going to be okay and the next day
when you're feeling like well yeah but
what about okay really pay attention to
the viscera of that moment to have a
prayer of recalling some of it think
about other people think about like how
great it would be to evoke the same
feelings in somebody else wow you know
vicariously doing that is a great way of
resetting Pleasures that we've
habituated to um and you know every
every parent has this at various points
where they say
wow my kid just got to experience this
for the first time it was amazing when I
did that it's you know there's all sorts
of means of doing it and of course you
got to have your your act together to a
greater extent than most of us readily
do but like these are these are all the
ways in which you try to keep the colors
from fading too quickly you hit on one
of the uh hot topics of the internet
dopamine obviously dopamine Nation the
fact that people are concerned they're
being driven by it they're compulsively
chasing it through a screen through a
vape in their hand through whatever next
Collective effervescence experience
they're having with their friends how
much [__] is there in your opinion
in the training detraining retraining
sensitivity detoxing of
dopamine um oh I don't know I'm trying
to be polite and not call it [__]
but thanks for calling it [__] um
it's
because people get hold in one
particular direction with it which
superficially is correct but is not
really the case in the reality is like
so much more interesting amid this you
know dopamine Nation stuff that's a
great phrase the equivalent phrase I'd
have is we're the species that wants and
wants and wants and wants and it's for
much the same reason okay what everybody
thinks they know about dopamine and what
all the the savants thought they had
shown for a long time time um is
dopamine is about
reward take a person take a monkey take
a rat give it a reward from out of
nowhere and it releases dopamine from
the dopaminergic reward circuits in the
brain there and yeah it's about reward
cocaine releases tons of dopamine like
nothing the natural world could ever do
so that by the way afterward you've
depleted your own dopamine stores so if
you want to have a big rush the only
possible you have is to do it again and
then do it again because each time you
come back to a baseline that's even more
depleted than you were before you know
the the ratcheting downward of addiction
but I digress in a preachy manner okay
so dopamine it's about reward that's
totally straightforward all these all
these euphoriant released dopamine case
closed but now you do the experiment a
little bit differently you take that
human rat monkey whatever and and you
know you put them in a room and here's
the deal when a little light comes on it
means if they go and press this lever 10
times then they're going to get a reward
great you learn it very quickly light
work reward light work reward and you
got it under your belt and that's
terrific and so the question now becomes
when that sequence occurs when does
dopamine go up does it go up when you
get the reward no not once you learn
this contingency dopamine goes up when
the light turns on because you're
sitting there saying yeah I'm on top of
this I know I know all about this lever
pressing stuff piece of cake this is
going to be fabulous dopamine's about
the
anticipation it's not about the reward
it's about this is going to be fantastic
and even more interestingly if you mess
in there and you block the dopamine
levels from Rising you don't get the
lever pressing it's about the motivation
driven by the
anticipation and this is like incredible
this is totally amazing in all sorts of
ways first off it begins to hint after a
while that it's not the pursuit of
happiness but it's the happiness of the
pursuit yes that sound bite I've never
patented that but that should be on
little doilies and everyone
kitchens and stuff that's what I mean
think about how often the anticipation
of something turns out to be much better
than it turns out to actually be bummer
because what you now have afterward is
even that much more of a hunger but it's
about anticipation so that's the first
interesting implication the anticipation
and the striving is what's really the
thing that that motivates us second cool
thing okay so now do the experiment a
little bit differently
um what I just described was you press
the lever you get the reward press the
lever get the reward 100% predictability
it's completely clear now shift things
to you press the lever and you only get
the reward about half the
time what happens to dopamine at that
point it goes through the roof the
second the little light goes on because
what you've just introduced into your
brain chemistry is the word maybe and
what oh maybe drives the system like
nothing on Earth okay I'm detecting that
my dog is frantically briefed because
his ball has rolled under something let
me go help him out in his his
patheticness I'll be right
back okay take
now oh yes look at you yes now okay
safie come so let me see oh and now the
other dog is here also now let me see if
I could keep him Satisfied by wrapping
him on the nose here and pretending to
be trying to pull the ball
away okay so you introduce some
uncertainty in it and there's even more
dopamine because maybe like you're now
sitting there saying yeah I'm a total
screw up but today I'm feeling lucky but
I'm sure I'm going to mess up but no I'm
on top and you're just teetering there
and that's motivating like nothing under
add in some
uncertainty and if you get the right
social engineering going on like people
do in Las Vegas they will take a one in
a thousand chance and convince you you
actually have a 5050 chance of something
wonderful and you just press that lever
over and over again um I'd say the third
thing that's coolest about it is you do
all this with a monkey or a rat and this
is about like you press the lever and
then after a 10-second delay you get the
reward and then we do the exact same
thing and we press a very human specific
lever and what we believe is somewhere
down the line we're g to get a reward
we're going to go to heaven after we die
if like you pray whoa we can lever press
like an entire lifetime we can lever
press for we're able to maintain that
anticipatory dopamine like nobody else
out there we can lever press in
anticipation that our grandkids will
inherit money from us like what is that
we take the same system and we could run
it like a million times longer than your
average monkey can and that explains an
awful lot as
well yeah I find it so interesting that
it seems like that kind of the the
bullseye of happiness is things are
about to get slightly better than I
thought they were going to be like
that's pretty much it right it's just
it's that moment just there it's before
it happens right it's not when the it's
not when the foods come out it's when
you see the waiter coming over with the
food and he's about to put it
down and okay here's one of the most
cynical things I ever heard someone say
this was a guy down the hall in the dorm
in college he said a relationship is the
price you pay for the anticipation of it
wow yeah yes yes he had one disastrous
relationship after another after another
I imagine yeah the word
almost whoa that's that's really
powerful and like that's how we you know
construct cities and like sequence the
human genome and build pyramids and all
that like just keep pressing the lever
because that's going to be amazing when
they stick your mummified corpse inside
that big paramal thing it's all going to
be worth it what about dopamine
sensitivity and and driving that either
down so that we become more sensitive to
we we have detrained ourselves from
dopamine so much there is advice online
you don't have any stimulus for 30 days
it resets things in the brain how long
does it take is it is it locked in for
life I I win the lottery once and now
every paycheck to me is it forever going
to seem poultry I've hit hit the lever
and got a million bits of food and now
no amount of food is ever going to feel
satisfying to me well well I I feel
fairly confident that if you didn't eat
for 30 days food would be amazing
afterward it would it would have reset
in a traumatic way um you know here's
just one piece of that story and again
kind of the world I come from if you're
a fetus and you're exposed to a lot of
stress hormones among all the other
things going on in there you make fewer
dopamine neurons in that part of the
brain you're going to have fewer of them
as an adult you're going to have less
capacity for feeling pleasure and
anticipation you're going to need
stronger stimuli to get the system
kicking into gear what have you early
life stress and vulnerability to
substance abuse that's exactly a
mechanism for it so yeah how how many of
those neurons do you have how good are
they at making dopamine how quickly do
they run out of it if they run out of it
how fast can they rebuild it if the
systems habituated how fast does it
reset and every single one of those
things has a nuts and bolts explanation
in each of us every one of those differs
in each of us from somebody else and
every one of those settings is a mixture
of genes and what happened to you when
and all of that and that's why you get
people who like go listen to a Vagner
Opera for four hours and find it to be
wonderful and other people who like if
they don't like you know shoot up right
now they're not going to last another
minute or so everything you know
individual
variation all right everybody's system
works differently we're talking about
stress we're talking about
neurotransmitters and hormones and some
of that stuff's contentious right but
largely people are interested in how to
reduce stress and how it works and how
the oxytocin and the serotonin and stuff
all come together why did you decide to
descend into the hellscape that is the
Free Will discussion like why is it so
important to discuss this that you would
put your own Mental Health on the
line um well when I was a
fetus there's this thing that happened
um well one I was almost back to a fetus
I I was 14 when I decided there's no
free will whatsoever um as long as I was
at it it was one very tumultuous night I
also decided there's no God and there's
no purpose to anything and it's a huge
empty rough evening for a
14-year-old yeah yeah and I've been
paying for those insights ever since I
even this was literally a two in the
morning I woke up during a rather like
distressed week with all sorts of like
angsty things going on and I woke up and
like I remember very clearly saying
oh I get it there's no
God and there's no Free Will and there's
and I even quickly wrote down notes
which of course were incoherent because
I was half asleep and I couldn't read
them in the morning but you know I've
been thinking this way forever um and
you know that's great that's kind of
what I've gotten to and about five years
ago I wrote this book uh called behave
the biology of humans at our best and
worst and it's basically why do we do
what we do and the answer is because of
what happened one second ago and one
minute ago and an hour ago and back to
Childhood and Fetal life and genes and
what culture your ancestors invented
because that's how your mother treated
you in evolution and all that and you
got to take all of that into account and
literally 790 pages agoni inly later you
know this is this is what we're about um
and the aftermath I did a lot of
lecturing and like you'd go through a
50-minute version of all of this and Q&A
afterward and inevitably there'd be
someone who would say
wow you know if all if this is how stuff
works we we may have less Free Will than
we normally think and I say you think
you think and I realized like for a
surprising number of people who would do
something as ridiculous as go to a
lecture on a week night or something
this was revelatory and saying okay I
thought this would be obvious after like
almost 800 pages of this
download time to write something that
says yeah not only is there much less
than we think there's no free will
whatsoever and we got to start
functioning a little bit more as if
that's the case and thus I've sat you
know
collecting cobwebs for the last five
years writing a sort of the sequel to
that book it's coming out October it's
called determined a science of life
without Free Will and I take what is far
in way a lunatic fringe stance which
isn't saying that we have no free will
whatsoever all we are is the sum of our
biology and its interactions with
environment and neither of which we had
any fundamental control over and that's
who we are um so I kind of figured I
would like go try to convince some
people of that and fully expect that's
going to be like wildly unsuccessful but
like at least I don't have to try to
frame my arguments and coherent
paragraphs
anymore why do you think the
conversation about Free Will is so
animated um because at first glance and
for the first 15050 or so glances it
really sucks if we have no free will if
we are just biological machines all of
that it really is terrible and
demoralizing and frightening and all of
that and it's not by chance that what
the poll show is like 90 95% of
philosophers who think about this are
what you call
compatibilists which is they're willing
to admit that we're not made out of
magic like the world was made out of
molecules and stuff like that but
somehow somehow somehow this is where we
still manage to have free will and when
you read between the lines it's because
half of them are saying because damn
that would be depressing if because we
get such we are me um me and where did
me come from and part of being me is
that like I've got some control over
what I do and this is incredibly Central
to our sense of well-being and mental
health and lots of cases and all of that
but like
bummer it doesn't work that way and you
know I go through like this agonizingly
long book the first half is like why we
have no Free Will and here's the brains
and the jeans and you know all of that
um and the second half of the book which
took took me much longer to write
because I still don't really have any
good answers to this is oh my God what
if people actually started believing
this how are we supposed to function if
we recognize that there's no free will
that agency is a myth oh my God like
what's the world supposed to look like
and the second half of the book is very
feeble attempts at trying to get at that
and hopefully in the process like de
deconstructing uh people's resistance to
the notion that we have uh no free will
um the first thing everybody immediately
freaks out over everybody's going to
just run a muck because there's no
responsibility if you feel like there is
none and what a lot of science has shown
is we're not going to run a muck we may
run a muck for the first afternoon we're
convinced of that and like interesting
research has shown if you like
unconsciously Prime people to believe
less and Free Will they're more likely
to cheat at a game 20 minutes later
stuff like that but when you get people
who have for a long time believed
there's no free will just as when you
get people who for a long time have
believed there is no God they're exactly
as ethical as people who believe there's
abundant Free Will and it makes sense to
hold us responsible for our actions and
just as ethical as people who believe
there is a God who is watching and
judging all of that and sort of the key
commonality is if you've spent a lot of
time thinking about
this what's the source of meaning what's
the source of human goodness or any
stuff like that if you spent a lot of
time thinking about it in lots of ways
it doesn't matter if your conclusion is
we have free will or we don't there is a
God or there isn't there is a God who
cares or any if you've done the hard
work of thinking about it you're going
to wind up being much more ethical than
average that's the F we're not going to
run them muck um but then people freak
out saying that still still there's
going to be some people that run a muck
and what you're going to do nothing
about them you're just going to let
murderers run around on the street
because they they're not responsible for
their actions and you know that's an
asinine worry because we've got some
great parallels if if you got a car and
the brakes don't work it's not safe it's
dangerous you keep it off the streets
cuz it's going to hurt people and what
you do is if you can't fix it you stick
it in a garage and the car can't be
driven anymore but that doesn't mean it
deserves to be locked up that doesn't
mean it's got a crappy Soul or something
like that it's a broken machine and
protect Society from it yeah I guess the
sort of criminal side of this is a
really interesting implication right
like if there's does does no free will
mean that there's no such thing as blame
and that punishment and
retribution and and Vengeance and stuff
are always indefensible right I think a
lot of the time what we see when we see
bad bad people people that have done bad
things um when we see them go to jail
there's something kind of righteous that
we feel we feel like they were given
their just desserts in some regard uh
and you need to use it as a um a tool of
disc enouragement for other people to do
it in future it needs to be a societal
signal but we also know that it's only
like a bit okay at that there's many
people who don't care about whether or
not they get caught many many people who
almost prefer to be in jail than prefer
to be outside people have become so
habituated to their existence in there
so yeah what does this do to a law
system that needs to be able to protect
us from people that are going to do bad
things if we are not the conscious
agents that have caused the actions that
we're now being prosecuted for well sort
of the the nuanced response I have to
that is the entire Dam system is
irrational and medieval and has to be
completely abolished because it's
premised on it's premised on the notion
that it is okay to punish people for
things over which they had no control
and that in passing brings up the the
point you just made as to why this is so
difficult we like to punish
one of the most reliable releasers of
dopamine in our brains is get to be
righteously punishing of someone uh yeah
that's going to be an uphill battle
because that feels good when we think
like we're doing it for the right
reasons but the criminal justice system
makes no sense at all even the reformist
versions of like you know reconciliation
ceremonies and and you know compensatory
actions on the part of people who have
done harm to better understand their
victims and their victims to better
understand them all of those are
premised on like bleeding heart liberal
versions of yeah the system could be a
lot less brutal and could work better um
the system makes no sense at all because
it is predicated on the starting notion
of it's a just World in which people are
punished for things they had no control
over and and that's the only possible
logical outcome so this is where people
freak out and oh no murderers running
around on the streets and all you have
to apply is the same Public Health
quarantine model that you do with a car
whose brakes don't work you keep it in
there but that doesn't mean like you
Dent the hood viciously every single day
to make it a better car afterward it
doesn't mean that what does this what
does this look like practically like
what what does this when it's not a
car okay we do one version of this like
all the time with a type of human who's
dangerous they're dangerous and if you
don't keep them like confined um in a
way that they can't get access to other
people um people are going to be harmed
by them and what is this this is when
your five-year-old has a cold and you
keep them hold from kindergarten because
they're going to get the other kids sick
from sneezing and we've all all learned
that as a quarantine containment
strategy and we're all able to protect
kindergarteners from Sneezy kids with
runny noses and there's no judgment
there's no responsibility you don't keep
your kid home because they deserve not
to be able to see their friends that day
you don't say you can't play with your
toys
because you know the way you're sneezing
don't you care about how you're going to
harm other people whoa we've managed to
do that and we keep kindergarteners safe
from nose colds and Society hasn't
fallen apart we've subtracted out a
notion of responsibility and Society not
only functions it functions better
because kindergarteners not only don't
get sick but you don't tell
five-year-olds they've got like the evil
demon in there that's making them sneeze
or something what about people that
would say Robert that sounds an awful
lot like jail to me that's what we do we
we take the people that have done bad
things and we put them in a quarantined
building along with people who also have
the same bad things for a period of time
and then we let them out um no because
it's a world of difference from
quarantine for one thing what you do
with quarantine what your moral
imperative is is to figure out exactly
what you need to do to keep people safe
from this individual and not a smidgen
more not an inch more than that because
there's no reason to take away your
child's toys just because they have a
nose cold you you do the absolute
minimum that is needed in addition you
don't moralize about it this is simply a
containment strategy and finally what
you do and you get all Society to look
at it that way I mean we've gotten to
the point where you know a kid who's
sneezing we don't view them as a moral
blight but yeah don't bring them to
kindergarten tomorrow they're GNA get my
kid sick and that's going to be a
disaster we've subtracted that out of it
we've subtracted that out of it
in some even more meaningful Realms
schizophrenia like one of the all-time
horrible diseases it usually gets you in
late adolescence early adulthood and for
decades and decades and decades like
somebody's child falls into
schizophrenia and you take them to the
doctor and it's the most tragic moment
of your life as a parent because the
doctor says yes it is that disease and
we don't really know how to handle it
and you know this is an enormous tragedy
and then as the parent you say how did
this happen What caused this disease and
for about the middle half of the 20th
century the best most compassionate
psychiatrist on Earth had an answer for
you which is you caused it you caused it
by your crappy parenting and of course
it was always directed at the mother at
your quote schizophrenogenic mothering
which amid sort of the Freudian build
that fueled it on some unconscious level
you hate your child you hated your child
and it's your fault your fault and I
have talked to like support groups of
like family members of people with
schizophrenia and the first generation
of people where they figured out oh no
actually it's a neurogenetic disorder of
brain developmental abnormalities it had
nothing to do with your mothering and
these are all women in their 90s now and
it is amazing to talk to them about the
moment when they truly grasped this
isn't my fault I didn't do this so as a
society we're able to like take care of
kids sneezing and we're able to subtract
out fault of mothers when it comes to
schizophrenia things like that and we're
able to do it in a way where we're not
moralizing anymore so you contain the
person you quarantine them the absolute
minimum needed and not an inch more and
you do it without morality and you do
the thing that like every good Public
Health person knows that their job
doesn't end at that point their job is
to then figure out how did this happen
in the first place why do certain sort
of inner city neighborhoods produce
criminals why is it that people who live
in poverty die of like diseases of Aging
when they're 50 years old why go do
something about root causes and it's the
same exact like moral and paral live
imperative Public Health people like dig
well so people can get clean water do
things so that people don't grow up
thinking that it's an infinitely scary
world and you have to watch your back
all the time and in fact here's a good
weapon to use when you want to
accomplish that like put those pieces
together and yeah it's obviously an
utterly transformed world but that's
exactly what we're doing with kids who
sneeze okay let's make sure the next
time I take my 5-year-old to soccer
practice that they like put their like
warm jacket on afterward so they don't
get sick and if they do it's not their
fault they're not evil and make sure
they don't get anybody else sick at
preschool but like don't punish them
beyond that and whoa we could run the
world that way and we could run the
world that way with schizophrenia now
and we need to move to the point where
we're running it that way with a whole
bunch of other stuff because it's the
exact same Pro profile and the exact
same ways in which we make all sorts of
people's lives miserable for no
reason and like we've done it before so
yay let's go do it again okay so after
we've [__] on the righteous retribution
that people want for criminals and
people that have done bad things from a
great height another pillar that people
are very very attached to me included is
meritocracy it's people being able to be
the architects of their own successes
and I had Sam Harris on the show about
three months ago and this was one of the
things that we didn't get to talk about
but I kind of wish that I'd brought it
up to him and he talked about the myth
of the self-made man and he said the
myth of the self-made man does so much
heavy lifting right of Center it allows
people to feel like they are The
Architects of their own successes and
Alanda Boton from the school of Life
gave me this beautiful framing years ago
on this great video he did where he said
um in ancient Greece the Beggars on the
streets the word that was used to
describe them was unfortunate that lady
Fortuna the Goddess that has the the
scales that she hadn't blessed them and
that's changed now into the modern world
the Gman clature that we use is a loser
right a loser is the person that hasn't
been able to get themselves up and sort
their life out it's been taken from
something that was almost bestowed On
You by an outside ethereal Force to now
something that was completely within
your valtion and and totally under your
control as a sovereign agent in the
world and the implication is if the
losers are The Architects of their
losses then the winners are The
Architects of their successes and this
myth of the self-made man all of the
rest of it I've made a lot of changes to
the way that I exist and the things that
I do and in the texture of my mind and
I've made a lots of changes over the
last six years and it does sound to me
quite disempowering and quite
disquieting to hear I didn't choose to
do any of that all of the effort that I
thought that I deployed wasn't mine to
choose my capacity to have that effort
wasn't mine to choose my desire to and
choice to put my foot on the pedal of
whatever that effort is wasn't mind to
choose in the executive function to
piece it all together into a structured
ordered organizational framework to do
it also wasn't mind to choose or to
deploy it makes for quite a sad world as
someone that wants to try and become
something it sure does which is why this
is totally depressing and yet uh this is
actually a good thing I mean for
starters everything I just said about
the criminal justice system just like
say opposite words in the same sentences
and it applies exactly the same to
meritocracy it is just as irrational and
just as in need of being like chunked
all together because like the other side
of this being like a horrible unjust
world is that we reward people for
things they had no control over and they
come out feeling entitled and feeling
like they've earned it and so that's got
to go also okay so what's the equivalent
Panic to oh great so you're just going
to have like murderers running around in
the streets saying oh great you're just
got to have like a randomly selected
person taking out your brain
tumor no like you got to have like
skilled people be neurosurgeons and some
people can gain those skills and other
people not and like you you need to have
competent people doing stuff and just
as
like you keep dangerous people from Hur
hurting people um you keep incompetent
people from hurting people as well and
like your neurosurgeons will still have
to go through a lot of training and all
of that um but that means the incentives
need to be there right you have to have
the incentives in order to be able to
justify them going through all of the
training and doing the hard things yeah
and what we went through was like the
usual incentives rep punishment have to
be subtracted out because incentives are
built around you're a rotten person and
you could be cured go talk to the
chaplain or whatever and the same thing
in the case of the like brain surgeon
flip the other way
um like the only logical conclusion is
thank God they're capable of doing this
but they're not a better human because
they can do this they don't they're not
entitled to have their needs and life
considered more than anyone else's so
where do incentives come
from you know major like oh my God it's
like almost Buddhist crap this guy's
going on about right now we are
motivated by the desire to attain
Prestige and power and respect and
entitlement and all of that and in the
case of like how they were talking about
those poor unfortunates not blessed by
Lady Luck back there um what we have to
take pleasure from is we were one of the
lucky ones to feel gratitude for that
that has to be a source of like okay
cool turns out it looks like I'm one of
those people who has the potential to
like be able to go save a lot of lives
to interject there why should you feel
gratitude for something that you had no
choice in it happening um because you
lucked out you you you're not living on
the streets You Led Out I've got the
balance sheet in my mind of the degree
of pleasure that people have from
feeling like they authored their own own
successes compared with the degree of
pleasure that they have from feeling
like they just rolled a double six yeah
this is asinine this is like utopian
beyond words but like somewhere in
there we recognize that like there's a
certain amount of irrational attribution
of of acclaiming someone when they turn
out to be 7 fo4 in tall and they're
amazing in the
NBA okay that kind
of you know that may begin to explain
why they're in the NBA and I'm not kind
of thing oh yeah that one we've gotten
to the point in society that that one
has something to do with versions of
like your growth hormone receptors and
that was not a moral like Triumph to
grow tall enough to play in the NBA we
can kind of deal with that and you know
Society hasn't fallen apart we can
subtract out
praise for somebody growing to be that
height and the world doesn't collapse
and it's a much more accurate assessment
but what we're getting at here is like
this enormous false dichotomy we do in
our heads which is like most people
don't believe in infinite Free Will and
they say yeah there's stuff we have no
control over like not everyone gets to
be s foot4
not everybody gets to have perfect pitch
not everybody gets to have the right
glutamate receptor makeup so that
they've got an amazing memory and you
know there's luck there's the biological
attributes that we get gifted with or
cursed with and there's that stuff yeah
we had no control over but oh what we do
with those attributes do we strive do we
show tenacity and gumption do we like
when the going gets tough do we get
going or do we we squander our gifts do
we indulge ourselves and Miss
opportunity that's the measure of who we
are that's this like totally false
dichotomy that our attributes are made
of biology and like what we do it it is
made of fairy dust whether like that
tests our
souls and like that's like the most
seductive thing like how can you not be
like I don't know these these
seven-footers playing in the NBA and
like a while back there was this guy
Mugsy Bogue who was 5 foot three inches
tall and he played in the NBA because he
was like amazing and how could you not
be inspired by that and the one out of
gazillion kids born into poverty who
somehow are now the CEO of something and
like there's so damn inspiring and
looking at the squandering is like so
pleasurably appalling to watch um I saw
in Forbes Magazine last year 70% of
wealthy families have lost their
fortunes by the second generation
because they just squander and oh my God
who could resist that yeah that's the
arena in which we are convinced that
like God and Satan are arm wrestling
what you do with what you're handed out
of here and like if you show
self-discipline or not if you have
admirable impulse control at a highly
stressful moment or if you fail dismally
if you any of those things it's made out
the exact same stuff as your memory span
and whether you're a good Sprinter or
not because of the muscle makeup of your
thighs and whether it's the same biology
it's in my opinion a much more
interesting biology and it's got lots to
do with that part of the brain the
frontal cortex but it's the same stuff
and not only if you are like like
horribly abused and grow up under like
nightmarish adversity not only is your
brain going to develop in a way that you
probably are not going to have a great
digit span among the other consequences
you're G to have terrible self-control
on the average because your frontal
cortex didn't develop properly and
everyone looking at you will have this
great calvinist sort of notion to apply
to you has no
self-discipline can never make
themselves do that at every juncture
they do the wrong thing they do the
self-indulgent thing and it's made of
the same stuff but yeah again there is
kind of this problem that like I I see
this all the time you talk to a bunch of
people who have come out to hear a
lecture about the brain and that sort of
thing and yeah yeah they all gulp if
you've convinced them in the slightest
that Free Will is a is a pretty suspect
concept they all Gulp and say okay well
we're going to have a whole different
view about punishment oh I mean
containing dangerous people and Christ
before it's over with we're going to
have to be like the Scandinavians and
whoa this is going to be hard and I got
a lot of visceral stuff I'm gonna have
to overcome there but if you want to
really know what I'm gonna have a hard
time with it's oh did I not deserve my
good salary did I not earn my college
degree because I was one of the ones who
always skipped the parties and went and
studied to that's where people really
begin to panic because that's going to
be the much harder one this philosopher
Daniel Dennett who's like a leading
compatibilist and he's very influential
and he's like a Charming speaker and
writer and
he's he's
medieval in how he thinks about Free
Will and entitlement and all of that and
like this quote of his that winds up in
all of his YouTube talks and interviews
and stuff where he's going on about how
like you know we need to hold on to the
concept of Free Will regardless of
whether it's true or not I happen to
think it's true he says and here are my
completely unsupportable scientific
opinions about it but nonetheless
because we don't want murderers and
rapists running around all over the
place die and what's gonna happen if we
don't feel a sense of accomplishment in
our
prizes whoa that's what he's actually
worried about you know [__] it with the
murderers running around what's going to
happen if I can't feel this if I earned
my PRI this is a Verbatim quote if we
can't feel a sense of accomplishments
for the prizes we've
earned yeah o now we know what the
problem really is for all of those
people with 10year chairs and philosophy
or whatever like that's where the Panic
comes in and what I spent like the five
years writing this book thinking I was
going to wind up with is like the most
unpalatable punchline on Earth which is
like tough this is how the world works
you really didn't earn those things it's
all chance it's biological luck it's
environmental luck so like you know suck
it up and be an adult with this wow
that's going to be really a fun message
to go out and try to sell people but
then you
realize this is actually fabulous news
the lack of Free Will is incredibly
liberating because it one when it comes
to this being a world where we reward
and punish people for things that they
were not responsibly for most of the
time we're punishing people most of the
time we're telling people who had the
crappy luck in life to be born in a
village in the Sahel where there's no
clean water or had the crappy luck to be
born into the wrong poor family or had
the crappy luck to not be beautiful and
thus for their whole life they have less
of a chance to be loved or the crappy
luck to have jeans that make them
destined for for obesity or any for most
people on this planet the news that you
were not responsible for how it turned
out is the most Humane damn thing you
can tell anyone and there's this
gigantic self- selection problem which
is the people who are going to come and
listen to some like nutty lecture are
exactly the people who are going to be
saying oh my God maybe I didn't earn my
college degree the people for whom this
is like the liberating message they're
sitting there wondering how they're
going to pay the rent at the end of the
week but they have no idea who Robert
sapolsky or determinism is and like
frontal
cortex because they're they're working
three jobs and like for most people on
this planet the news that all we are are
end products of all the things we had no
control over beforehand is the most
Humane possible news you can get and a
world that adjusts to thinking that way
you know it's it's a very good thing
that we decided not to take old women
with no teeth who live off by themselves
on the edge of the Hamlet and decid it's
their fault that there was an earthquake
and burn them at the stake it's a more
Humane planet that we learned something
about witches in the biological reality
every one of these things is going to
make for a more Humane planet and as
soon as we figured those things out the
world got better for the majority of
people so this is actually a good thing
like bummer if you were left with this
existential void and on top of that like
your business school degree is a little
bit less source of a sense of
entitlement in you but for most people
on this
planet like a justice system that is the
backbone of everything that we do which
says that reward and punishment is
just because it's being met it out to
people who we incorrectly believe earned
it all I could do is make the world
better so like this is a good thing I
sure can't really think that way most of
the time because most of the time I'm
saying oh my God but what about the fact
that like I have a job they pay me I've
got like a good salary all of that whoa
I sure worked hard for you know nobody
is saying this is going to be easy but
all that happens at every step when we
subtract
responsibility out of our perception of
where human behavior comes from it
becomes a nice your
planet yeah it seems to me that taking
the Free Will red
pill is
something that hurts people who have
much to be proud of but benefits people
who currently have much to be kind of
despondent about um it it's it's like a
a flattening way it's the ultimate
itarian philosophy right it's as flat as
flat
gets yeah because if you do the
impossible and really really think this
way all the time and I sure as hell
can't but the only logical conclusion
from this is none of us are entitled to
anything more than any other human on
earth there's no person out there whose
needs are entitled to less consideration
than yours so I I I understand that but
from a practical consideration you know
if we're talking about the importance of
incentives in order to be able to get
people who have the predisposition or
the capacity to be able to deploy that
in the right way presumably we can't
just red pill free will into all of the
potential budding brain surgeons out
there so that they know even though I
only get paid the same as the guy who
has bottom of the barrel
conscientiousness and just smokes weed
and does Xbox box all day because he
didn't choose that and I didn't choose
this it should be my duty to ignore the
lack of incentive in this new world with
of Ubi or something like Free Will based
Universal basic income I I'm guessing
that that's not your proposal for like a
society structure well good luck with
that yeah that's not going to be easy on
the other hand we've got a world where
from very early on in life we're
training kids with cultural myths that
are exactly the opposite um I don't know
if we put a lot of work into teaching
people to just recognize it a sheer
utter chance that they wound up being
who they are and if you had the good
luck uh you know some gratitude would be
a good thing okay okay my Christ I'm
going to start I'm going to bring Joan
bz here in a moment on like her walker
or something to talk about the utopian
like yeah but we do it in little bits
and pieces um you know like there's
there's like Hallmark cards you can get
and give to somebody that says what
what's it thank you for being
you like oh come on thank you for you
having been the lucky one to have turned
out the way you are and happening to
like be my spouse or yeah it's going to
be really hard and I can function this
way less than 1% of the time and I
constantly show that like amid believing
this stuff I'm a total hypocrite because
I can't really act on it emotionally the
vast majority but every now and then
when it really really really matters
like think about it when you're trying
to make sense
of why it seems okay that this person
gets less concerned than people like you
do or try to think that way every now
and then when you're about to be like
pissed off at somebody or self-righteous
or whatever or really really think like
you should be able to be in the front of
the line because after all um I don't
know it's interesting you know being a
professor at Stanford where the students
are great they're all smart and they're
great kids and they're
like they like uniformly worry about the
world and they're wonderful and a huge
disproportionate percentage of them came
from ridiculous material Andor Andor
intellectual privilege and most of them
spent a lot of time trying to wrestle
with this because they realize you know
it's not by chance they wound up there
and it was just and that's you know when
you dig beneath the surface of those
kids who were like going off to help run
a free clinic in Nepal or whatever it's
not just to get into med school it's on
some
level they realize where they're at and
like go look at a bunch of people in the
prison a mile away from Palo Alto and
the fact that way are they are way
disproportionately likely uh to not have
parents who read books to them or like
lived in a neighborhood where you could
walk home at the end of the day and feel
safe and you know that whole song and
dance and yeah it's not going to be easy
but like at least do it at some juncture
where you're feeling like you should be
able to get to the front of the line and
remember you didn't earn
it I sent a 40 minute clip the original
40-minute clip of Sam telling Joe Rogan
this on his podcast I think it was maybe
eight years ago when it came out and I
think about five years ago I sent it I
used to work in nightclubs it was funny
that you mentioned earlier on about
about clubbing um I gave it to I listen
to it and explained it on the night at
one of our events I explained it to the
manager of one of the venues and he was
like interested in in philosophy and
stuff Luke Irish dude fascinating guy
and uh he like oh I'd love I'd love to
learn a little bit more about that so I
sent him it and he was spiraled into a
deep depression for two weeks because I
sent him this 40-minute video and he
came back two weeks later and he had to
take me to one side and he said uh hey I
need to have a word with you and I was
thinking oh god what have I done now
have I let somebody in that's not got
the right ID or has one of our boys done
something and he was like that uh that
Sam Harris video that you sent me it's
like uh yeah I didn't get out of bed for
like two full weeks because of that I've
used up all of my sick days and like at
work and all this [__] so can you
provide people with some glimmer of a
white pill that makes them feel a little
bit less despondent about the fact that
why shouldn't I just not do anything all
of the things because I do think you
know even if on mass and over a long
enough time span people end up just
going back to their sort of habituated
routine with a slightly ambient sapolsky
in the back of their mind reminding them
that it's not the it's not they're not
the architect of their own successes
it's uncomfortable right to to genuinely
try and grapple with this uh it's
uncomfortable it's uncomfortable in the
same way as realizing that eating
Factory farmed animal products is
basically like paying sentient creatures
to be tortured for your pleasure um
and people need a little bit of help to
get them across the line do you have any
uh Viagra to help them get through this
slightly difficult
situation well this once again is going
to be a pretty lame answer adid amid the
absolutism of there's no free will
whatsoever all of that like go do
something incremental once a week when
you realize you're about to judge
somebody and harshly like don't or once
a week when you're like making you know
pounding on the desk of some poor
bastard where you're insisting that you
had an appointment and you're important
and they're delaying you
or whatever like do one of those things
once a week like at some point like look
at somebody very different from you and
really try and exercise and they had
absolutely nothing to do with how they
wound up or you know a little little
instead of small Random Acts of Kindness
Small random acts of rejecting Free Will
and like okay I can't do much better
than that but like go do that go do that
every now and
then I think again I feel like Sam
Harris has been here with in the
conversation with us I had it when I had
him on the show I asked him kind of
something similar to do with mindfulness
because I've done a lot of meditation in
especially over the last 5 years and I
mentioned that it it felt like kind of
pressing down on the accelerator of a
car that it can achieve even good
momentum but as soon as you put your
take your foot off it the momentum
starts to slow and sometimes way quicker
than you would like I was
asking I I wanted to know whether
ultimately I'm going to reach some
enlightened Bliss out State man where I
just lie under trees man and love life
and what I like do I think it's
important that what you've sort of come
to is if somebody wants to take this
particular Free Will red pill and even
if the ethical philosophical
implications are super Universal and
kind of everything gets upended and and
and the entire world would be totally
different the sort of day-to-day
practical instantiation of what you're
saying is just think about this a little
bit just string these together string
these kind of insight moments together
every so often or as often as you can or
as often as is is is useful and Sam had
something similar to do with mindfulness
you know he mentioned um he was late for
the show he was late getting out of the
door and he was rushing and he was
rushing and him and his wife were
getting ready at the same time and they
were going past each other and whatever
whatever and then he said before he got
out of the door he caught himself and
realized that you know he's in this
marriage with this woman that he loves
and he just took 10 seconds to scoop her
up and give her a kiss and then he left
and he was like ultimately mindfulness
comes down to stringing together as many
of those individual instances as you can
and I love that I love that as an idea
because it seems so much more graspable
to me it seems so much more achievable
for me to try and do 10 times a day my
mind just be where my feet are [__]
for once right and then maybe I can do
it 20 times a day maybe I can do it 30
times a day maybe some weeks I don't do
it at all and then I come back and I try
10 times a day 20 times a day 30 times a
day and maybe with the Free Will thing
maybe that's the same too maybe it helps
us to be less judgmental maybe it helps
us to feel less [__] Superior and and
and and vengeful and
yeah maybe it is maybe this maybe you
need to speak to someone and get this as
a part of a meditation course so that
they can let go of their resentment God
no not that anything but that um yeah I
I I wish I had Sam's growing capacity
for
Spiritual Solace and stuff more
drugs heavy more drugs you need to take
more heavy psychedelics and see if your
capacity for free will is uh is
maintained through that through no free
will of your own obviously yes well my
problem is I never did none of that
stuff but yeah which there's something
oxymoronic in that which is saying oh
like this reform undercuts Revolution
reform oh let's try to remember this
person's circumstance before we lock
them away for 50 years instead of 60
years oh reform little incremental stuff
that's a there's no free will we need a
total Revolution and suggesting here
that implementing this revolution in
this little baby step incremental
reformist kind of way but like yeah why
not I mean on a daily
basis like if any of this stuff is true
it makes as little sense to hate
somebody as to like hate a volcano um so
every day I try to find the means to not
hate Donald Trump or Vladimir Putin or
that bastard kid who was incredibly mean
to my son once 23 years ago and like
okay let's let's work at
this you know a little bit at a time I
really appreciate your work I really
appreciate the way that you put this
stuff together I've had an awful lot of
fun together it's been a long time
coming to get you on the show I'm really
glad that I finally did well thanks this
was a blast this was really
fun where should people go if they want
to keep up to date with the things that
you're doing oh well this book coming
out next month
October okay once again call determine
the science of life with oh [__] what's
it called determined the science of life
without Free Will you'd think I'd have
that one sorted out by now SP five years
writing it and you can't remember the
[__] my my my poor publicist just had
like apoplexy if listening to this okay
determine de sence of life without free
will uh penguin Random House in your
neighborhood grocer soon all of that you
know everything I've ever said or
thought in the last five years I've
written down and there so like I got
nothing else useful to say than that and
even that may not be but okay that's
that's where you could find it go go
help Jeff Bezos get richer it's
available there too fantastic Robert
thank you for the day sure thank you if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to
[Music]
subscribe